as soon as the show came out so that i
moved out to california
we both happen to be homeless this is
one of my favorite things about our
history
the way that we competed to see who
could stay homeless for the longest
yeah it was awesome we uh we saved a lot
i mean i
i know i yeah we saved a lot of money on
rent and and just
i mean there was no reason to have a
residence like that was one of the
funnest times ever
where were you living chris at the time
wherever we were yeah i mean
he did mtv cribs out of his car i
remember that was the [ __ ] greatest
thing of all time
but were you actually living in your car
then i remember seeing that be like
there's no way
oh it wasn't like i go to sleep in my
truck every night but like some i
i mean i i did sleep in my truck
sometimes but but
mostly just stay where i was a vagabond
for four years how long did this go on
for we were couch surfers okay
how far along who won i didn't rent a
place for probably eight years
of my life eight years pontius pontius
won by a lot
i was too much of a drug addict you know
it was too much work to like
to like post up and do [ __ ] cocaine
for three days in a row when you didn't
have a home base yeah
you know the nomadic [ __ ] cocaine is
just no fun
so i tapped out and got an apartment and
just [ __ ] holed up and did drugs man
yeah you got one of those apartments
that has the big phone number like on
the side
like side of the building because uh
i guess it's easy to remember
hollywood's so we it's such a
a like a transient place like
like so many people come and go you know
yeah they come with big
it is true they come with big dreams and
a lot of those people with big dreams i
met
like at your house
like yeah going through those old videos
of steve's old house would be like
like a an older dude in a suit sitting
on a couch next to a gangster and you're
like
what the [ __ ] is going on here
steve steve's fair-weathered friends
yeah dude